il ya une autre affaire qui est sorti ce
week-end c'est la sphère neymar neymar
est accusé d'avoir violé une jeune femme
dans un hôtel à paris
l'attaquant du psg nient les accusations
et dénonce un piège de la part de la
jeune femme alors que sait-on exactement
de la faire on vous a préparé un petit
récap des faits et juste après on aura
un homme qui viendra nous voir et qui
connaît tout sur les scandales de
football qui va tout nous raconter que
c'est parti l'information est tombée
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
neymar footballeur star du psg se
retrouve dans la tourmente suite aux
accusations de viol d'une jeune femme
brésilienne des faits qui se seraient
déroulés à paris il y a quelques
semaines ces deux puissantes aux amarres
au brésil que la jeune femme a porté
plainte contre le célèbre numéro 10
selon elle
suite à plusieurs échanges paroisse de
sap avec la star ce dernier l'aurait
invité tous frais payés à se rendre à
paris le 15 mai dernier c'est ce soir là
qu'il serait venu la voir dans sa
chambre du sofitel visiblement en état
d'ébriété et qu'il aurait utilisé la
violence pour avoir une relation
sexuelle avec elle
si le footballeur ne nie pas qu'il
échangé des messages avec la jeune femme
et qu'il l'a fait venir à paris selon
lui la relation était consentie et il ne
s'agit en aucun cas d'un viol sur les
réseaux sociaux il a décidé de prendre
la parole pour faire valoir son
innocence c'est triste et très mauvais
d'être accusée d'une telle chose c'est
triste de constater que des gens veulent
extorquer les autres j'espère que la
justice va lire les messages et va
trouver la vérité c'était un piège et je
suis tombé dedans si la justice est en
train de faire son travail pour démêler
le vrai du faux
cette affaire n'est pas la bienvenue en
ce moment et entache un peu plus l'image
du joueur déjà quelque peu écornée ces
derniers mois vraiment je voudrais
remercier jérôme jessel d'être avec nos
journalistes et auteurs alors jérôme
c'est le spécialiste vraiment du
football et surtout de tout ce qui se
passe en dehors du football vous avez
écrit sexus footballisticus qui en latin
bien survenir le sexe footballistique
sexe football club
merci d'être avec nous déjà jérôme merci
voilà parce que franchement c'est une
encyclopédie jérôme et c'est pas un mec
qui raconte des conneries il a vraiment
enquêter
ces voix là c'est quelqu'un qui est
extrêmement sérieux alors la sphère
neymar tout le monde en a parlé ce
week-end on a tous reçu des alertes moi
tout le monde m'appelait t'as vu des
barrettes a vu neymar est terminé marc
et abus neymar déjà dans mais c'est vrai
que c'est un truc de fou
déjà vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez
de cette affaire et après jérôme va
essayer de nous aider à démêler le vrai
du faux dans cette affaire
j'ai au moins moi j'ai envie d'avoir la
vie de raymond parce que je pense que
raymond il était comme moi
mine de rien
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire encore on était un petit peu
choqué par ce truc ce qui est embêtant
c'est qu'on parle d'alcool on parle
d'une soirée où il ya de l'alcool donc
peut-être que la fille elle a fait des
trucs avec lui ils ont fait la soirée
son parti à l'hôtel peut-être qu'elle a
dinan et lui l'a dit oui et c'est là
c'est là qu'il va falloir prouver la
vérité mais moi là où je me dis j'ai ma
deuxième version est peut-être que je
vais dire encore des conneries mais
c'est quand même un mec qui gagne 100
mille euros par jour cent mille euros
par jour on est marquant six mois tu
mets dans la chambre avec neymar quand
je ressors avec neymar chevaux comme ça
je porte plainte
j'ai dit qu'il m'a violée ça peut être
aussi la poule aux oeufs d'or c'est que
c'est un truc comme si tu avais gagné au
loto mais par 26 millions par an cs dit
bill va me donner
il va me donner des dommages pour pour
pour étouffer la sphère où je ne sais
quoi c'est compliqué de dire ça mais il
faut quand même laisser faire l' enquête
parce que si ça se trouve il s'est
vraiment passé un truc ça se trouve la
fille elle a vraiment dit non c'est
comme dans le clip en d'orange elle
tente non c'est non et ça se trouve elle
même je veux me tourner vers giroud
avant d'avoir votre avis giroux avait vu
ce que dit raymond parce que je voulais
avoir la vie de raymond le produit parce
qu'une raymond c'est ce que dit ce que
dit la plupart des gens qui ont encore
un moment
et raymond c'est vrai que c'est voilà
c'est c'est un petit peu voilà il est
lui il parle toujours avec son coeur il
dit ce qu'il pense et il ya plein de
gens voilà moi j'ai entendu plein de
gens dire ça alors j'ai déjà pourquoi
neymar alors pourquoi neymar parce que
neymar c'est la star du foot mondial
c'est le mec bling bling qui montre sa
vie aussi à travers les réseaux sont son
compte instagram je crois que ces 118
millions de followers c'est énorme
ouais donc c'est vraiment une star des
réseaux sociaux c'est une star
planétaire après qu'il agace et il agace
parce qu'il a le côté bling bling sur le
temps j'ai rencontré moyens en dehors
les gens qui réussissent à voilà donc il
a un talent supérieur à la moyenne il
fait beaucoup de jaloux
effectivement nous on n'était pas dans
la chambre à coucher donc on peut pas
vraiment se dire là ce qui est compliqué
dans ce genre de cas c'est que c'est
toujours parole contre parole
en revanche ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
c'est vraiment une tendance dans le
monde actuel dans le monde du foot
actuel d'accuser des
les grands joueurs de foot de viol
rappelons nous que ronaldo a été aussi
dans le viseur et que l'on enquête est
toujours en cours sur un présumé viol
datant de 2009 à las vegas aujourd'hui
c'est neymar il ya beaucoup de 2,2
d'acteurs du monde de football de
brandao 6 1 au brésil assure il ya huit
ans en arrière
réal web aussi voilà et finalement s'est
rendu compte de quoi que finalement la
plainte a été classée sans suite il faut
vraiment être prudent se méfier
aujourd'hui dans le monde du football on
accuse quasiment tout le monde même le
président de la confédération africaine
de football a été accusé de harcèlement
donc c'est toujours un moyen de salir la
réputation des gens de est vrai qu'au
brésil c'est que ces courants alors au
brésil ce qui est courant en fait selon
ce sont les filles qui courent après les
footballeur
ah oui on les appelle les mariachis tera
est littéralement ça veut dire les
femmes qui s'accrochent aux chaussures à
crampons des joueurs et leur but parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de profs de pauvreté
au brésil c'est d'avoir un enfant avec
un joueur brésilien pour assurer ses
arrières et c'est arrivé par exemple à
ronaldo le joueur brésilien qui avait
tellement d'enfants à droite et à gauche
qu'il a décidé de faire une vasectomie
par exemple neymar aussi a eu un enfant
avec une sex friend et c'est donc c'est
quelque chose de très courant au brésil
alors là ce qui est un peu nouveau
si vous voulez c'est que là on est
plutôt dans le registre je dirais du
chantage
en tout cas on n'a pas encore tous les
éléments mais il se pourrait que en tout
cas c'est ce que dit le père de neymar
ils ont réagi très vite que cette jeune
femme aurait demandé de l'argent pour
acheter son silence ce qui était arrivé
pour ronaldo rappelez vous que dans le
dossier ronaldo ronaldo le lendemain du
présumé viol a payé 350 mille dollars
pour étouffer la faire est-ce que là on
est dans ce même schéma
c'est possible alors on dit qui y est
voilà c'est pourquoi les footballeurs
c'est vrai que vous avez une théorie sur
les footballeurs parce que c'est vrai
qu'il nous dit que ce sont des proies
faciles alors ce sont des est-ce que la
mine de rien la sq on va se dire est ce
que disent les gens aussi alors il ya
une jeune fille qui porte plainte
et là on en train de retourner une
histoire oui alors ce sont des proies
faciles les footballeur parce qu'ils
sont riches est ce que pour vous
souvenez des footballeurs les pros alors
bon je dis pas qu'ils sont totalement
victimes parce qu'il ya eu des affaires
effectivement sexuels qui ont eu cours
dans le monde du football où la
culpabilité des footballeur était était
démontrée mais il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont quand même hyper
hyper entouré ils sont hyper coach est
justement sur ces dangers là vous savez
que désormais dans les centres de
formation de football
là où les jeunes son apprenti
footballeur il ya des psychologues qui
viennent justement pour l'épauler vous
pour les frais les avertir de tous les
dangers qui vont les gaietés quand ils
vont être le joueur à 20 à 20 ans ils
sont multimillionnaires pas parfois
et effectivement ils peuvent aussi
dérapé ça ça existait alors pas non plus
complètement
voilà les déculpabiliser mais il ya
quand même une tendance à chercher quand
même les footballeur pour pour un
business alors regardez la réponse de
donner ma vie je vais tout publier
toutes les conversations que j'ai eues
avec cette femme pose d'un seul au monde
tous les moments passés avec elle
cela relève de l'intimité mais il est
nécessaire de rendre publiques ces
preuves pour montrer qu'il n'y a là rien
d'important c'est fou alors parce que
oui je raconte une anecdote il est
maintenant ce qui se passe aussi
c'est vrai qu'il ya plein j'ai vu des
potes footballeur je connais beaucoup de
footballeurs qui me disent maintenant
avant mine de rien de faire quelque
chose m'a pardon faire quelque chose
avec une meuf ou et qu'une fille avec
voilà même que ce soit sérieux ou pas il
se filme avec la fille juste avant voilà
pour montrer que vraiment r non je vous
jure que c'est vrai il vivait avec elle
voilà pour dire voilà comme ça ils me
disent ils font tout ça maintenant
voilà c'est parce qu'ils ont ils ont
très peur voilà qui qui voilà qui est
des quais des débordements comme ça
maintenant
moi moi je vais vous dire le problème
que j'ai avec cette affaire que si c'est
pas vrai le problème c'est que ça
dessert est plein de jeunes femmes et
plein de femmes qui sont victimes
vraiment victime et qu'après on dit bah
oui bah c'est oui mais voilà bah c'est
pas vrai c'est comme la sphère neymar
c'est comme la faire je ne sais pas
malade et ça ça c'est extrêmement grave
djoudi pour les femmes qui sont vraiment
victime
de viol et ça vraiment et c'est ça moi
c'est de ça que j'ai peur c'est cette
dérive
voilà alors je vois là franchement
j'espère voilà que que ce que c'est pas
beau là que j'espère que c'est pas son
cas cette jeune fille ben voilà où je
suis là où je rejoins c'est autant tout
à l'heure je dis ça mais qui gagne 100
mille euros par jour donc c'est
peut-être facile de la loterie mais là
où je te rejoins c'est des gens n'a pas
l'habitude d'entendre le nom on leur dit
pas non à ces gens là donc c'est
vraiment attention dire un mot non mais
le manga ça c'est pas de la faire si
elle a dit je veux pas lui l'a pas
l'habitude d'entendre non et ça sauve il
a été pour de vrai alors c'est toi la
nature des jeunes non mais la fia l'a
quand même traversé l'atlantique jouerai
jamais vous plaît elle s'est fait payer
les billets d'avion par neymar ben ça va
être très bien que elle savait très bien
qu'elle dit qu'il n'avait pas lu compte
et ça c'est une certitude
après ils se sont échangés depuis mars
d'aidé mais c'est là qu'un accès y avait
déjà eu il faut une espèce de drague
c'est pas parce qu'un gars monsieur
daumier d'avion c'est ce que vous
envoyez des nude en l'occurrence qu'elle
a fait non parce qu'elle lui a donné le
sentiment que si au dernier moment elle
a décidé d'assurer qu'elle lui dit
finalement en fait pardon mais non bah
oui ben non c'est non même si ces deux
minutes avant même si c'est trop alors
les risques d'un super course j'aurais
d'abord christine kelly d'abord oui il
est d'abord pour redire qu'il est
convoqué vendredi par la police parce
qu'elle a diffusé les photos et et les
échanges ce qui est un petit peu dommage
mais en votant heureusement qu'il a
quand même diffusé parce que ça permet
un peu de la disculper et puis c'est
vrai que ça fait quand même ça jette
l'opprobe sur les vraies victimes ce qui
y est demeuré ça et on ne sort pas
savoir réellement ce qui s'est passé
c'est sa voiture sous surtout sans
sauverait victime ou mathieu comment
peut-on encore avoir un goût du verdon
mais quand on n'a pas les infos et
photos
quand on n'a pas les infos faut juste du
bon sens quelqu'un qui a été violée qui
étaient pris de panique
la première chose qui fait c'étaient les
porter plainte séparée
commence à penser à négocier on est déjà
plus du tour dans un lieu en étant
d'amener gras mais alors pas du tout il
ya des personnes ils sont très choqués
qu'ils ont besoin et corrections queiroz
a eu on a eu plein de témoignages -
mathieu dans celle ci on a eu plein de
témoignages de jeunes filles sous vide
qui était tellement choquée et avait
tellement peur voilà qu'elle pouvait pas
aller porter plainte qu'elle pouvait pas
en parler qui gardait son aile pour
nager une chose intéressante dans la
nature des échanges qu'ils ont eus tous
les deux c'est qu'elle va parler dans
une image footballistiques d'un match
retour
voilà donc elle va dire est ce qu'on
voyait ce qui aura un match retour et
ses sous-entendus dans les échanges
est-ce que après avoir exactement avec
lui c'est ça est ce que l'on fera
l'amour une seconde fois il se peut que
la justice brésilienne demande à la
justice française de l'aider notamment
pour avoir accès à la vidéo surveillance
puisque les faits se seraient déroulés
sur le sol français
et puis on sait en échec mais j'étais
pas dans la chambre évidemment je vais
pas juger de cette propre histoire mais
quand et neymar etc
on a plus de mal quand même à fermer la
porte pour empêcher les filles de
rentrée que d'essayer de les faire
rentrer c'est les mecs comme qui payent
des gardes du corps pour empêcher les
fuites se glisser dans la chambre
d'hôtel quand ils sont pas là pour se
cacher sous le lit comme il ya eu plein
de groupes de rock qui font ça quand
même
donc c'est un mec qui ne dépend il était
pas un chien si le style et si c'était
juste un besoin sexuel
il suffisait qu'il dise au garde du
corps m'a dit et dit je suis là il ya
quarante mètres 49 qui vont venir
et bah oui vraiment amateur ça que je
veux dit oui c'est parce que c'est
neymar est ce qu'il est populaire parce
qu'il est beau gosse que c'est pas un
prédateur sexuel mais voilà j'ose
espérer qu'il est innocent et peut-être
capable à cette histoire il est innocent
et pareil quand on dit gagnent beaucoup
d'argent mais c'est parce qu'il a
beaucoup d'argent que c'est pas non plus
un prédateur sexuel jeu désolé rappelez
vous la faire dsk dominique strauss kahn
avait dû voir et pourtant il a été
condamné
il était jugé coupable donc là où elle
errait réponse parce qu'elle envoie
aussi des nude qu'elle consent à la
halle aux rapports sexuels et au final
vous l'avez très bien dit ce qui fait
c'est que ce mouvement de libération la
parole ben oui mais à quoi bon
finalement est ce que les hommes vont
être les victimes alors qu'on doit
absolument pas ça les femmes restent
victimes et dans la sphère cinémarine
innocents malgré tout son nom est salie
ses proches ont salué ans ils se disent
neymar est un violeur sauf que c'est
trop tard
l'information a fait le buzz et le rabot
dans deux ans est jugé innocent nous
retiendra la sphère neymar non voilà moi
non mais le problème que j'ai avec cette
affaire je vous le dis c'est que moi
j'ai vu un peu les réactions de
certaines personnes et 90% des personnes
lésées oui c'est une jeune fille qui
veut de l'argent c'est de face à ça
c'est très grave parce que
pour toutes les femmes qui sont vraiment
victimes de viol derrière ça s'achète le
doute et mine de rien je vous dis ça
fait ça fait beaucoup de mal ce genre
d'affaires oui voilà et donc moi c'est
moi c'est ça qui me dérange mais voilà
moi j'ai vu j'ai vu un peu l'opinion
publique et j'ai regardé un petit peu
sur les réseaux sociaux
tout le monde disait basse et une mytho
c'est tout sauf ça c'est très grave
grave pour les jeunes filles qui ont des
vrais problèmes
si je peux exprimer un petit mot en plus
partons c'est pas un perdreau de l'année
ça fait des décennies qu'on ne vous
énervez apprécié des lycées de la
formule on appelle ça des starbucks
heures ils le savent
enfin quand tu lis je me suis fait
piéger c'est tout c'est une housse et
pas seulement à rousset une andouille
maintenant il ne sait que c'est facile
il devrait se méfier en état d'ébriété
d'alcool tous et tout est facile et
d'ouvriers doivent se méfier pardon ils
doivent se méfier c'est 3 yves rossy
enfin le village et roger géant qu'est
ce qui peut arriver à nema et qu'est ce
qui va se passer maintenant
d'abord ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'il a
vis de communiquer mais ça je trouve ça
paraît qu'il a très bien communiqué et
en plus il a bien fait pas attendre
ouais exactement ça en général en
communication de crise plus on attend et
plus ont fait naître les spéculations là
il a employé un ton solennel
on voit un et marc on a rarement vu un
très sérieux très factuelle qui s'appuie
aussi sur et là il prend quand même un
énorme risque parce qu'il va montrer des
photos d'intimité entre lui et sa copine
fourchette pas comment comment laver
cette rencontre et là c'est une première
dans le monde du football où un
footballeur de ce niveau là va aussi
loin dans le dévoilement de sa vie
intime et privée donc ça c'est assez
remarquable pour pour être noté qu'il a
été obligé de retirer aujourd'hui il a
été obligé de retirer pour des durées
les a écoutés d'ailleurs bon il nous est
très bien entouré des marques des bars
et une pme à lui tout seul c'est 300
millions d'euros de sa valeur estimée
sur le marché il est entouré des
meilleurs communicants des meilleurs
avocats
donc il effectivement le droit et de
quoi se défendre
maintenant et c'est vrai on dit toujours
calomniez calomniez il en restera
toujours quelque chose
là je joue nicolas sarkozy quel âge déjà
qui ça fait deux ans qu'il a paris il a
déjà un petit peu de souci de bien
s'installer de gagner parce qu'il arrête
là sa saison à chaque fois au mois de
mars il a du mal à vraiment créer un
vrai lien avec le public et ça c'est
vraiment pas de nature à arranger